let's go to our caller from the 503 area
code
um what's your name where are you
calling from 503
hi my name is louie and i'm calling from
portland oregon
uh how are you how do you guys even have
phones working there i heard that
everything was destroyed oh
i'm i'm super sorry yeah i i we we
we've been trying to keep it a secret
that that portland was just
completely leveled and raised and
there's just nothing left
um but but we got we we still got some
uh
bars out here that are close to dakovic
although our uh
restaurants are still uh open and such
um
which i don't mind bragging a little bit
that organ is doing pretty
well when it comes to infection rates
and things like that
well that may be but i'm sure i'm sure
you don't have any running water anymore
right
oh absolutely not all the running water
needed to be used
for uh biden's uh boater rally
of course of course so
um i do have so my question for you
concerns the 13th amendment of the
united states constitution
which uh section one reads uh neither
slavery nor involuntary servitude
except as a punishment or crime whereof
the party shall have been duly convicted
shall exist within the united states or
any place subject to their jurisdiction
right and my question to you
is does this exception mean that
a form of slavery is still legal in the
united states
my understanding of that is that if you
are
in prison and there is a work
requirement
in prison that it would be
constitutional now that my
my reading may be totally wrong but that
that's my understanding of what that
means
and i i believe that you are uh yeah i
i'm with you on that
um and the reason why i say that is that
uh in oregon we've had a
prison work requirement since 1994 right
person's convicted and as
and and because of how it's enshrined in
the constitution
prisoners do not have to be paid minimum
wage right
the work does not have to be safe um
and and i'm also looking at it as
both a uh and of course you know
california
which is fighting wildfires can't pay
their uh convicted
firefighters shall we say um the two
dollars a day that they've done
in the past so um and
and that's just scratching the surface
my goodness so
um but i just wanted to
uh kind of get a sort of second opinion
on it
uh yeah that's my sense of it that's my
sense of it and certainly
prison work conditions are a big topic
and something uh we've dealt with on the
program before and
hopefully something that when things are
more normal in this country we can
actually
deal with in a sane way yeah
uh absolutely absolutely um and i'll uh
i'll uh keep my eyes peeled for anything
changing on that front uh and of course
if if in portland if we rebuild the city
no i'm saying that in chest yeah the uh
um and uh as far as uh and i am hoping
that everyone does stay safe we've uh
we have some counties in the metro area
approaching evacuation orders for
wildfires and
everything else so it's a uh it's a real
confluence
or configuration of emergencies here
it's an amalgam we could even call it
louie from portland i appreciate the
call
thank you very much david take take it
easy all right you too
uh we are going to go to a break that is
going to do it for live calls today as
always
my sincere apologies i throw myself at
your mercy
that i was unable to get to every caller
but that means we'll have some callers
next week thank you